foreign
GEOS with us in Orlando hi Geo welcome
to the Ramsey Show
good afternoon how you doing great how
can we help
so I have a question I'm 23 years old
and I live with my parents and I'm and
I'm kind of on the fence if I should
move out or should I stay here with my
parents what do you make what's your
income
um I make 30 000 a year I'm just oh
actually I just started working with HP
one Aetna Medicare for about three
months now so it'll be 30 000 a year
um I have no nothing in my savings
nothing in my bank account I'm starting
from fresh
hp1
you say are you selling insurance
no sir um basically a CSR agent so
um
um in enrolling um prospects okay all
right
uh
well I mean Orlando at thirty thousand
dollars you I want you to get out as
soon as you can get out for your sake
because you will have a higher quality
life your development uh into adulthood
emotionally will be faster when you pay
your own light bill and you clean your
own laundry and you buy your own eggs
for the refrigerator right and but
thirty thousand is pretty tight so I
might hang a couple I mean let's let's
develop a plan that by may you move out
or something like that and during that
time let's try to get your income up and
during that time let's see what uh what
we can do to to you know to make sure
that when you move out you may be with a
roommate you create a budget situation
where you can afford the apartment or
afford the little house or whatever that
you're renting but um uh but in general
the faster you can move out of the house
in your early 20s the better it's going
to be for you 10 years from now
NGO I'll give you some homework to do
here start to research the areas around
you the apartments what is out there
what's the price and I would definitely
get roommates I had roommates just about
up until I was married so unless you're
making crazy money and you want to get
your own place and it makes sense where
it's not more than a quarter of your
take-home pay for example then you need
to get a roommate and uh you might need
to get that income up beforehand you
might need to have some money in the
bank for initial deposits with wherever
you're renting and so you have a little
bit of groundwork to do but you're close
man
right right exactly and um I I have been
doing some research and I see a great
apartment around this area uh it's for
about 900 bucks one bedroom and 1200 for
a two bedroom there you go I'm thinking
of so I was thinking about
um getting the one bedroom myself but I
was speaking to my brother about getting
us the two bedroom
um but I'm kind of on the sense of
living on my own because I've been
living with him for so long so I just
want to be on my own right now but I
don't have a vehicle so should I
purchase a vehicle first yes you need to
buy a vehicle you need to pay cash for
it that's A1 absolutely and that'll get
you in a position to do that